immer drastischere maßnahmen zur
bekämpfung des corona virus immer mehr
fälle und jetzt hat es auch diesen
prominenten politiker erwischt friedrich
merz er hat bestätigt dass er positiv
auf das corona virus getestet wurde
darüber möchte ich sprechen zu gast ist
bei mir bild vize paul ronzheimer
herzlich willkommen
was weiß man genau über den fall wo ist
friedrich merz jetzt für dich märz hat
via twitter und per mitteilung klar
gemacht dass sein test positiv war er
hat sich testen lassen am vergangenen
sonntag gesagt er bleibt jetzt zu hause
also sozusagen in quarantäne
er hat aber zuvor ja einige
veranstaltungen besucht unter anderem
auch eine veranstaltung mit glaube ich
über 700 gästen wie geht man da jetzt
vor weiß man genaueres darüber wissen
wir noch nicht genau ist aber fakt ist
am mittwochabend also wo bereits
sozusagen der korona virus weiter sich
verbreitet hatte gab es noch eine
veranstaltung mit friedrich merz mit
sehr vielen menschen und da stellt sich
natürlich jetzt die frage wen hat er
dort möglicherweise infiziert eine frage
die wir auch abstellen können
cdu-generalsekretär day uns jetzt
zugeschaltet ist guten tag im jahr
guten tag vielen dank dass sie sich zeit
nehmen hatten sie denn kontakt zu
friedrich merz haben sie ein
gesprochenes wie geht man jetzt mit
dieser lage um
wir haben gesprochen wir haben uns ja
auch mit den kandidaten ausgetauscht und
das haben wir über eine video schalte
gemacht das letzte mal also zwischen
armin laschet und norbert röttgen und
annegret kramp karrenbauer und friedrich
merz und mal gute besserung und ich
würde mir wünschen dass alle sich so
verhalten wie er nämlich jetzt auch dann
das zu befolgen was angeraten ist
nämlich zu hause zu bleiben in
quarantäne
aber haben sie die sorge herr ziemlich
dass sich bei dieser veranstaltung am
mittwochabend möglicherweise menschen
infiziert haben und daran anschließend
wie gehen sie als generalsekretär jetzt
generell um mit parteiveranstaltungen
und wie geht sieht es aus in der cdu
zentrale
da vertraue ich voll und ganz den
gesundheitsbehörden vor ort die das
einschätzen die ja bis heute versuchen
die kontakt ketten nachzuvollziehen und
es werden ja auch entsprechend personen
die mit personen kontakt hatten einen
positiven test haben ja unter quarantäne
gestellt das ist wichtig und das ist
sinnvoll aber das wie gesagt ist jetzt
keine politische einschätzung sondern
eine einschätzung der fachleute vor ort
wie sicherlich auch in diesem fall und
wir als partei haben den parteitag
abgesagt weil wir es nicht wenn nicht
nur für angemessen sondern wir halten es
für nicht vertretbar
ein parteitag in diesen zeiten
durchzuführen wir haben in allen
bundesländern im prinzip alle
veranstaltungen runtergefahren abgesagt
weil jetzt geht es nicht um
parteipolitik jetzt geht es ums land und
wir alle haben eine große verantwortung
ganz besonders in der politik aber alle
menschen in diesem land haben die große
verantwortung gegenüber ihren
mitmenschen das einzuhalten was jetzt
gefordert wird nämlich möglichst auf
viele soziale kontakte zu verzichten
abstand zu halten vor allen dingen hätte
sie merck wann haben sie den herrn merz
zuletzt gesehen wann sie denn mit ihm
zuletzt beisammen die inkubationszeit
beträgt ja nun um die zwei wochen jetzt
ist er positiv getestet lassen sie sich
auch testen
das ist schon länger her dass wir
zusammen gesessen haben insofern ist das
jetzt mache ich mir persönlich keine
sorgen aber es geht ja nicht nur ums
friedrich merz sondern es geht um die
vielen fälle die wir haben wir sind
jetzt alle gefordert die ausbreitung des
virus zu verhindern
zumindest zu verlangsamen das ist das
was jetzt möglich ist und deshalb mein
appell an alle
bitte halten sie sich an das was von den
gesundheitsämtern von den
landesregierungen und auch von der
bundesregierung empfohlen wird hellt
sich merklich sprechen über die
maßnahmen in deutschland jetzt in den
bundesländern umgesetzt werden
aber in unseren nachbarländern gibt es
noch drastischere maßnahmen der
französische präsident makro spricht gar
von krieg wie gehen sie mit dieser
rhetorik um finden sie das europa das
möglicherweise auch deutsche
stand im krieg ist ich finde jetzt kommt
es nicht auf worte an sondern um auf
kluges handeln
wir brauchen auf der einen seite
natürlich keine panik in unserem land
aber wir brauchen konsequentes handeln
und ich will das ganz deutlich sagen so
wie das gerade in der koordination der
bundesländer funktioniert die maßnahmen
die gemeinsam ergriffen werden und vor
allem wie dass der
bundesgesundheitsminister ihren spaß
macht das ist etwas was genau das an den
tag legt was wichtig ist auf die
wissenschaft zu hören auf der einen
seite und auf der anderen seite
konsequentes umsetzen dessen was die
wissenschaft empfiehlt aber gehen sie
davon aus dass es in deutschland
möglicherweise in wenigen tagen auch
eine ausgangssperre geben könnte das
kann heute noch niemand vorhersagen
wichtig ist damit es keine weit und
notwendigen maßnahmen gibt es dass wir
uns an die maßnahmen halten die jetzt
verordnet sind um eben die ausbreitung
zu verlangsamen
aber keiner kann ihnen heute verlässlich
eine aussage darüber treffen was in den
nächsten tagen notwendig sein wird oder
nicht mehr notwendig sein wird
und dennoch hat man das gefühl dass in
deutschland lange gestritten wurde die
bundesländer waren uneins hat
deutschland zu langsam reagiert also wir
haben erlebt dass sie wenn sie sich
anschauen wie stellen wir nicht nur die
gesetzgebung auf den weg gebracht haben
bei der frage wirtschaftliche hilfen
sondern im prinzip von wenigen stunden
ganz wenigen tagen es jetzt doch ein
koordiniertes vorgehen der bundesländer
gibt dann kann ich sagen das wird jetzt
ja auch umgesetzt in den kommunen
verhandeln wir mit klugen ratschlägen an
diejenigen die jetzt verantwortung
tragen zurück weil es jetzt an der zeit
ist der regierungen klug und
entschlossen zu handeln
und deswegen jeder handlung hat auch die
volle unterstützung aus der cdu
aber dazu gehört auch nicht nur die
bekämpfung des virus sondern auch jetzt
an diejenigen zu denken
die besonders unter den auswirkungen
leiten wir hatten
unterstützungsmaßnahmen für die großen
banken in der finanz und eurokrise
und jetzt brauchen wir entsprechende
maßnahmen
für die kleinen für die mittleren
betriebe in unserem land da geht es vor
allem um die gastronomie um
veranstaltungstechniker um andere
gewerke die jetzt die betroffen sind
es gibt ja auch bereits zahlreiche fälle
von kleinunternehmen die wirklich jetzt
schon in not sind um ihr geld fürchten
zu machen müssen was kann da konkret
getan werden an wen sie sich wenden wenn
jetzt die ersten geschäfte zu machen und
die menschen ratlos und vor allem ohne
gates alleine zu hause sitzen also
dieses bundeswirtschaftsministerium hat
eine entsprechende hotline auch
eingerichtet
und da bitte ich alle die jetzt
betroffen sich an diese zu wenden wenn
es um das thema steuern geht wenn sich
auch an das örtliche finanzamt und
beantragen sie entsprechende stundungen
auch das ist alles auf den weg gebracht
und wir jetzt liquidität braucht auch
ein überbrückungskredit dem wird
geholfen und insofern glaube ich dass
wir in den nächsten wochen noch über
weitere maßnahmen sprechen müssten aber
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt bitte kontakt
aufnehmen die entsprechenden hotlines
kontaktieren damit allen geholfen wird
ich möchte nicht dass hier
unternehmerinnen und unternehmer
selbstständige kleine betriebe
unverschuldet wegen dieser krise dann
vor dem aus ihrer existenz stehen
altmaier der gesagt jeder job ist sicher
stimmt das ich finde wir müssen jetzt
alles dafür tun dass dieses versprechen
auch erfüllt wird ich kann für den teil
der cdu sagen auch in der
bundesregierung die cdu wird alles aber
wirklich auch alles dafür tun damit
arbeitsplätze erhalten bleiben und dass
auch existenzen gerade von kleinen und
mittleren betrieben auch weiterhin nicht
gefährdet sind
sie sagten vorhin man kann noch nicht
absehen was alles auf deutschland
zukommen wird die frage ist was ist ihre
persönliche meinungen die menschen
sollen zu hause bleiben wird diese
ausgangssperre kommen ob sie kommt oder
nicht mag dahingestellt sein aber was
denken sie sollte sie kommen normal ich
bin der festen überzeugung dass wir das
den wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern überlassen müssen
welche empfehlung sie dann auch der
regierung geben
ich kann sagen aus meinem alltäglichen
erleben dass ich doch beobachtet dass
viele wie ich finde zu viele menschen
das was bisher schon angeordnet ist
nicht ernst nehmen und das macht mir
große sorgen wenn ich große gruppen auch
von jungen menschen sehen die bei diesem
wunderbaren wetter alles verständlich
gemeinsames feiern und sich sehr nahe
kommen dann fehlen mir dafür die worte
weil das ist nicht verantwortlich vor
allem den schwächeren und auch den
älteren gegenüber jetzt in der linie
auch der strafvollzug für unter drei
jahre ausgesetzt werden was bedeutet das
kann man jetzt salopp gesagt verbotenes
anstellen und darf dafür erst mal zu
hause bleiben
nein ausdrücklich nein straftaten werden
konsequent verfolgt und selbst in einem
bundesland wie berlin wird das so hoffe
ich auch in zukunft der fall sein
aber wie soll das konkret umgesetzt
werden die gefängnisse sind voll auch
dort muss man ja auf abstand unter den
gefangenen achten das heißt es können im
moment eigentlich auch keine neuen
gefangenen dazu ja was meinen sie wie
kommt das bei der bevölkerung an wie
soll das gehandhabt werden wenn wir
jetzt im prinzip auch noch verbrecher
unter uns haben wir werden keine
gefährlichen verbrecher gehen auf freiem
fuß lassen
das kann keiner verantworten und
ansonsten werden die länder
entsprechende maßnahmen ergreifen um
dafür zu sorgen dass ich auch dieses
virus nicht in den haftanstalten
ausbreiten kann aber noch mal niemand
sorge zu haben dass gefährliche person
in der öffentlichkeit zum laufen hat sie
mir die letzte frage an sie
wie gehen sie persönlich mit dieser
corona krise um sie sind selbst
familienvater sie wohnen in iserlohn und
berlin wie trifft es ihr umfeld und wie
gehen sie als familie damit um
ich empfinde eine große verunsicherung
auch in unserem freundeskreis was heißt
das jetzt eigentlich es ist ein großes
thema die kinderbetreuung also wie kann
man arbeit und die betreuung der kinder
zusammenbringen das ist für viele
menschen ein großes problem das erlebe
ich auch in meinem freundeskreis und
eine große verunsicherung
auch einen großen wählen auch in meinem
freundeskreis sich daran zu halten das
was jetzt die behörden angeordnet haben
aber es ist so dass die nächsten wochen
auch sehr sehr schwierig werden für
viele familien machen wir uns nichts vor
das sind hier keine ferien weil man soll
nicht mit anderen kindern auf einem
spielplatz spielen man sollte sie nicht
zu den großeltern bringen
jeder der kinder hat oder vor allem der
auch mehrere kinder hat weiß dass das
eben eine große herausforderung ist
kinder auch zu hause dann zu bespaßen
sie das persönlich praktisch wie geht
ihre frau damit um haben sie angst jetzt
in dieser situation angst ist nie ein
guter ratgeber in diesen situationen wir
selbst haben auch keine angst aber wir
machen uns natürlich große sorgen was
ist mit den älteren mit den kranken
unserer gesellschaft und wir auch als
familie wollen unseren beitrag dazu
leisten sowie das tausende
hunderttausende von deutschen momentan
tun
herzberg in berlin schließen jetzt alle
geschäfte nur die supermärkte die
apotheken und bankfilialen bleiben offen
noch mal die frage wie für wie
wahrscheinlich halten sie es dass in der
kommenden woche doch eine ausgangssperre
auf uns zukommt das kann ihnen jetzt
noch niemand sagen das hat etwas mit der
ausbreitung des virus zu tun die frage
ist greifen die maßnahmen die jetzt
ergriffen worden
schon so dass die kurve nicht so schnell
steigt und danach muss man das auf
wissenschaftlicher grundlage neu
bewerten
aber man sollte jetzt nichts
ausschließen man muss dazu sagen der
berliner senat das vorgeschlagen sie
sollen schließen es ist noch nicht ganz
durch aber es scheint so als würde sich
in den nächsten tagen noch viele
maßnahmen ankündigen auch die bundeswehr
versucht ihr zu unterstützen in welchem
rahmen kann und soll sie das tun wir
haben bei der bundeswehr an starken
sanitätsdienste es haben sich über 750
freiwillige reservisten gemeldet die die
streife unterstützen wollen im
sanitätsbereich das finde ich ein
starkes zeichen und ein großteil wird
auch eingesetzt werden und gerade mit
dem know how der bundeswehr und auch mit
dem kapitän
sie täten im sanitätsbereich kann die
bundeswehr einen beitrag leisten und ich
bin froh dass auch annegret kramp
karrenbauer verteidigungsministerin hier
ein klares zeichen setzt die bundeswehr
steht zu unterstützung bereit
ja in berlin wird ja ein krankenhaus auf
dem messegelände geplant für bis zu 1000
personen auch da wird die bundeswehr
unterstützen hält sie merkt vielen
herzlichen dank dass sie sich für uns
zeit genommen haben
ich danke ihnen